[Music]  do you know what my job description is  I'm in acquisitions I look up and I  catch what falls out of the sky  what I should  tell me about the mission did you see  anything unusual it's above our bakery  I get a cookie now look I get it  something went down in Mexico nobody  wants any witnesses we need to know if  you can you map owes a threat  we're Rangers it Baxley if your mom's  vagina were a video game to be rated E  for Everyone posing the three kind of  the [ __ ] point  [Music]  predators just don't sit around making  hats out of rib cages the conquered  space but that's not what's on the  horizon should I be worried  Riley I think you know what is on the  ship the ultimate predators we may die  we're still here  so come and get us [ __ ]  [Music]